que les français sont encore
figurez-vous très attachés semble-t-il à
la monnaie à l'espèce à avoir du cash
sur soi et c'est ce que nous explique
bfmtv réglée en liquide
le mode de paiement le plus utilisé en
france surtout pour les petites dépenses
69 % des achats de moins de 20 euros
ce fonds en espèces et ce n'est pas
qu'une question d'âge malgré les
applications sur téléphones prisé par
les plus jeunes
même si les plus jeunes sont un peu
moins attaché mais ils sont quand même
73 % à se dire attaché aux espèces et à
ne pas souhaiter voir leur disparition
en moyenne les français en 42 euros dans
leur portefeuille
une manière de bien gérer leur but et du
mois mais plus de 2500 distributeurs de
banques ont disparu entre 2015 et 2017
au risque de créer une nouvelle forme de
fracture sociale dans les zones rurales
une personne sur quatre estiment que
l'accès à l'argent liquide s'est
dégradée alors 86% des français
préfèrent le liquide pour les dépenses
du quotidien pour aller acheter la
petite baguette le truc comme vous dites
qu'ils sont fous non j'ai dit c'est fou
par sont fourvoyés sinon il c'est fou
vous savez pourquoi j'ai l'impression
qu'à chaque objet un billet ben je vais
le dépenser dès que je le casse dès que
je casse un petit billet à la presse je
suis trop dépensière oui mais ce que
c'est pas une façon aussi de
matérialiser l'argent et de se dire ah
bah tiens là je sais exactement ce que
je en train de dépenser donc je me ferai
l'impossible il faut mourir les doigts
il s'est brûlé des films ils volent ils
courent ils s'envolent de l'ema tandis
qu'avec mon petit mon petit téléphone et
mon paiement avec le mobile c'est
parfait série donc vous voudrez fait
également pas d'espèces même pour un
achat du quotidien une baguette un
nombre non paiement sans contact et
téléphone d'accord dirais ok question de
génération peut-être
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
déjà il est en anciens francs alors bon
les blagues de vieux que je sais je sais
même plus ce que c'est que le franc
alors non mais pour vous dire non le
garde de m
tu l'as dis toi même c'est que l'argent
se brûlent des douanes est de coutume te
rends pas compte de tout ce que tu
dépenses en faisant le sans contact
c'est un vrai problème c'est quand on ne
se rend pas compte on dépense beaucoup
plus donc vous préférez les espèces
saint-louis bateau - les espèces
s'affairent ça fait mal
ouais voilà forcément vous dites il ya
un truc du chapeau 1 euros vins bon ça
va aller y a un truc vous allez le payer
50 4 euros en cash avec je vous voudrais
c'est pas la même que celle que tu nous
tiens mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
thibault vous êtes d'accord on va
c'est décevant de voir mes amis et mes à
ce point le sans contact parce que les
français aiment le cash
ils aiment l'argent parce que c'est la
classe on a des billets pour tous les
français tributaire habillé on va la
banque de france c'est comme ça que les
français
et vous vous avez beaucoup de billets
sur vous bien sûr j'aimerais j'aimerais
beaucoup pas répond il faut être dans
cet imaginaire parce que sinon je ne
ferais jamais d'abord alors d'accord
donc c'est pour ça que vous préférez les
apaise bien sûr d'accord mais pas la
petite monnaie j'imagine que ça ne sert
à rien d'accord j'ai eu un problème avec
la petite monnaie nourry abondé ça c'est
sale ça oui mais vous avez des vous avez
des vous savez déjà les dangers dans
votre sac et ça c'est encombrant moi si
j'ai dix centimes sur moi c'est le sait
le bout du monde est effectivement tout
à la carte
ah bah ouais là d'accord ok très bien ok
bon bah écoute est d'accord mais bien
sûr bien évidemment pour régler vos
achats vous privilégié comme mode de
paiement cartes bancaires argent liquide
ou chèque on a posé la question alors le
chagrin est tombé 2 % si on n'a pas le
choix on y va mais ça l'est vraiment que
chaque parce que sa banque les cales
faut savoir écrire oui c'est vrai mais
là faut la carte bancaire pour 82% est
large et aux liquides 6%
nos téléspectateurs ont fait mentir le
sondage sur les français le liquide
puisque je vous disais que ils étaient
86 % à préférer colle liquide pour les
petites dépenses